[Music]
you have hardcore fans
tom they've created a website called
celic waterfall
sandwich picks
it's pictures of you
yeah uh and with sandwiches
in beautiful settings yeah
here's you with an italian oh that's a
sandwich
that's a beautiful sign that's a good
sandwich that's a good sandwich and a
beautiful i think hawaiian location here
you are with a reuben i believe
on a 1980s phone i was looking at the
phone yeah here you are with peta i
think that's a pita pocket
and a golden amulet here you are with a
blt
here you are with peanut butter and
jelly and oh that's nice
and uh here you are where are you in
that oh and there you are with the
torta what is it that's a dreamy one
that's kind of neat i want that for my
dressing room i really do
and then finally this is the best one
for you
just peeking out of the water i love
that one those are what a fantastic
tribute to you the dreamy one where i
was you know kind of half there and half
not that's that's that was kind of my
style that's the one you want yeah do
you want me to get that for you no they
used that thing in king kong though then
no but i'm going to get that for you i'm
going to have that mounted and presented
to you and it's and will it hang in your
home if i give it to you
yeah i'll put it in my den
because it's kind of butch
and it'll look good in my den
that's not butch at all sure
that's kind of a butch
oh i only saw it for a second
enjoy this artwork this is yours now
thank you i give this to you